did you ever lose any piece of jewelry
never lost any jury knock on some wood
somebody knocking some good okay
yo yo what's good it's your boy Juicy J
you watching T cube on the rocks
I've been collecting jewelry since the
early nineties it was mainly Jay Z they
really inspired me I started seeing all
the diamond is all that platinum stuff
he was wearing I got to give me some
platinum I got to give me a platinum
watch you know he would always say man
you got to be wearing platinum you can
be wearing no silver so I like [ __ ] that
silver [ __ ] I'm buying platinum cuz
Platinum cost more than six it's the
watch right here I wore to the Oscars I
was on stage we gotta me award I'm
jumping around the stage with this watch
I almost felt like my arm you know mean
a lot you know my first at this this was
like the watch you know I slept with
this watch on you know you have diamond
doubt platinum Rolex family yeah this
watch right here this is a Joe rodeo I
wore this at the Oscars
so wait were you wearing both at the
Oscars yeah what two watches yet I've
been wanting to watch this before
anybody start wearing two whites I'd be
like this is something new I'm gonna do
something new two watches both set at
the wrong time as I used to do it man I
wish I could have brought my grills I
got some crazy gurus I got this Platinum
grill with these diamonds in it I forgot
to bring it smoking too much damn weed
they bringing some of them photos from
the hostage you can see this grill I got
this crazy platinum diamonds everywhere
cost me like 50
[Music]
this is a special watch right here I
remember buying this watch I was at Wiz
Khalifa's crib and my accountant he
wouldn't get it for me we accept this
condo in Hollywood and I came downstairs
and I was like yo man appreciate that
this is like a piece that remind me when
I first started going so long might as
well is like 30,000 this watch right
here I call the Plain Jane
I didn't want no diamonds in his watch
sometimes it's all about the Diamonds
you know I wanted something just what a
nice cool face on it and just go to
lunch dinner bar mitzvahs you know yeah
I actually like this more than any other
watch a lot of times I don't feel the I
need the flash all the time I'm more
like the flash on the clothes when I go
to Barney's I have to make run out of
there man because I've been in spent all
my money in barns this is the hypnotized
mind symbol as I recollect where three 6
mafia started we started on this record
label ties behind project Pat little
white Frazier boy you know gangster boo
it's so like this is like very historic
this is from the 90s I sound of music
back then and in the 90s people now call
it horrorcore we caught a kid book music
you know saying it doesn't have the
spooky look you know it's a special
right here this is a Taylor gang sign
you know we're gonna made me a co-owner
of the label they gave me this another
Taylor Gang chain we gave me you know
I'm saying that's not to help arrest the
Taylor Gang offense spray-paint can you
let me get the paper plane right there
what is this paper plane symbolize man
you fly you smoke it you have Taylor
game they roll it on paper planes
most recent this one right here when I
went when I went solo I was just like so
happy so I was like man let me give me a
nice big ass cubed link something super
hard
fifty thousand cash reached in my Louis
bag and I just like the usual I've seen
these I was like man this reminds me of
like a genie in a bottle or something
you know I got that color you know look
like something from overseas or
something I think I bought a bunch of
stuff I think I bought it this it may be
dead at the same time about this and
probably these two so I just wanna
there's a bunch of cash my just reaching
the bag never look back that's how you
guys do it I called it the blessed bad
you don't see me reaching that II feel
those blessings in them in this ring
right here is special to me this was
given to me from my father-in-law sri
lankan peace a couple of diamonds in
their little ruby in the center it's a
crown on this ring right here feel like
I'm a king when I have like a ring with
a crown on some diamonds something you
know some bling turn the lights on me
turn lights off it was gonna blind a
little bit yeah I just treat myself man
you know I'm I'm feeling the vibe I just
I'll call it TV Johnny be like giving it
some rings man you know you had that
money you had a cash on you want to spin
it so bad
Yeti's every minute yeah I see I see
something nice I just grabbed but I
wanted something to just stick out
something real crazy big full five
diamonds put in the one you know one in
the center man I really don't remember
when I got my ears pierced but I believe
I got it at the mall I was ready to put
some big diamonds in my ear man I was I
was hyped up well I want to get another
piece I probably get this piece that I
seen this old rap group problem of you
never heard of Eric being rock him Eric
be had this broke with this big eagle if
I was a gift something it's gonna be
like crazy stupid just something just
make them well [ __ ] be like what the
[ __ ] is they hanging out Monday I'm
gonna walk like this gonna be so heavy
I'm gonna come back and show it to you
too it's gonna be crazy
maybe like a $300,000 piece if I if I
drop a new album this year and if it
goes to five times platinum then I'm
going about I'm about everybody wanting
watches for everybody [ __ ] everybody
go stream that new single I got out
neighbor fishing Travis Scott produced
by Buddha bless the beat shut the [ __ ]
out help it go plan help finish it out